Oh God for that he's over I can't
believe it
oh my god for tonight it's gone what am
I gonna do
minecraft gamers minecraft welcome
welcome six-year-olds play minecraft
alright
you don't have to clean for tonight do
you understand you don't have to play
for at night for all your boomers
watching basically for at night shut
down their servers and left with a black
hole oh my god that means the game is
over right oh my god we did it yesterday
snare wahoo
dummy dumps it's a marketing ploy me and
intellectual for that players right now
be like you know it's a meme but it's
also actually reality except they're
little children what is wrong with our
society what is society who said
violence video games huh who says it
rules of the Internet anything popular
there will be memes fortnight ends as
Epic Games Twitter goes dark and game
servers go offline finally and there
peace at last even Musk the absolute man
lied he did it he bought fortnight and
deleted that would be so baller I would
make him so happy
how much is fortnight can i buy
fortnight when fortnight servers come
back online and the new season begins
read it how dare you still be alive how
dare you that was a good attitude by
impression but black ops for fails to
kill fortnight apex legends fails to
kill fortnight Tetris fails that night
fine
ok myself fight oh this stained my desk
Oh God
Yemi for now has been deleted realizing
nine-year-olds are all gonna come to
Minecraft
oh I see this as absolute win when
Michelle Obama flushes toilet
Thank You Michelle Obama for nothing as
usual fortnight ends as epic games
Twitter goes dark and game servers go
online the evil is defeated like as much
as I wanna be like yeah cool they die
they're not gone they're not gone
don't celebrate 14 year olds when
fortnight gets shut down all of reddit
wouldn't be funny if everyone just moved
on
people stop playing and it was like they
keep they come back with his new map and
everyone's like so excited and then no
one cares change the world my chip I
approve this meme for the first time my
final message goodbye goodbye gum bye
bye hey door hey door go go bye bye come
in city vodka throw full of fun streaky
cute okay when fortnight and when
fortnight ends I'm gonna do it I'm gonna
do it
fortnight going offline ash publicity
stunts their fan base finding better get
their list fine abetik here's to play
while it's down and switching over my
fellow 6 year olds take this pickaxe
it's yours
Call of Duty epic legends mortal kombat
minecraft fortnight wheels on shopping
cart be like ooh the first black holder
heard megalovania must have been like oh
my god it's sands it's cents how can
fortnight be so popular and so widely
hated at the same time it making no
sense
to be fair I commend them it is a good
PR move my respected but that's about it
next meme joke you're getting hit by car
haha you guys watch The Joker yet great
movie great film we saw it yesterday
I stopped probably 50 people from saying
the n-word but other than that it was a
good time me with good greats healthy
body great friends good dick sites
depression that God gave me because he
had to nerf me sorry this one is to Opie
nerf depression bye bye enjoy me when I
come to public speaking me when I start
talking that's interesting I'm the
complete opposite I'm always I would
switch these around and then it would
apply to me several good memes with a
fresh template
cold pictures me trying to rise up
communism in theory communism in
practice wow this is so deep the AC is
on he has food and is listening to his
favorite music what song is it listening
to gamers please don't break the window
me an epic gentleman gamer society oh my
god
when Joker said Society in the film I
got mineral chills I got literal shields
piercing through my body and I scream we
live in one and everyone applauded
that's true story it happened yesterday
at cinema it was epic
only three homework questions one a 1 C
1 B 1 B 1 then I just do the meme where
I read them in the wrong order
unintentionally epic Blizzard trying to
please how bit my trying to please China
everyone dumped it
we'll get into this meme in a minute
what if we kissed at the Joker session
Joker stares that's the Joker stares oh
my god what if we kiss there I should
bring Marcia that would be the power
ultimate Power Move can you imagine
bringing your gamer wife and kissing at
the holy in siliconed my god gamer rises
up did you just hit and run Ronald
McDonald it happens to the best of us
you just gotta move past in life alright
you can literally add any car driver
meme to this which what makes it so good
me and my dad accidentally running into
my friend and his dad oh that's so cute
I love these tiny little Photoshop means
they're so adorable oh when I say any
car it works there it is you dumb bit a
serious film I pet the man slowly lost
his sanity because a horrible he was
treated by everyone around it society
there's a word for it society just say
it I know people are afraid to say the
word but just say it there's a stigma
there's a taboo but the more we say it
the more we break the taboo and we break
boundaries say it with me
society not everyone around
and you cowards funny car meme haha
funny car mean he got hit by car hahaha
make kwok-him Phoenix say we live in a
society in the new Joker film one has
signed well at least we tried we almost
had a said society I think that's an
absolute win religious destination Joker
stairs
five stars damn I gotta find it can you
actually search the Joker stairs
is there a live feed there or something
I want to see what's happening we should
raid the Joker stairs next nothing shows
up with Joker stairs there it is there
it is funny
Joker stairs why don't they show up I'm
being oppressed why don't they show up
Thomas the Tank Engine never seen such
blue yessiree this makes me angry this
makes me want to rice rice up and go
beyond I do not need to obey the rules
of Road drat I should have obeyed the
rules of the road that was an
informative road safety video I just
remembered actually put over to consume
my cereal this meme is garbage
environment corporations billionaires
you dumb bit yes the environment is all
rich people's fault for selling me
things that creates problem in
environment how dare those rich people
maybe you're the dumb bit oh did you
know corporation is responsible for all
the emission okay so how does car
companies exist then well it's got
buddy's fault oh not me what if we
kissed at the Joker stairs think about
it oh my god I would love think about
bringing Marseille there gives me shells
absolute Sheila's boss my little brother
couldn't be my little brother me time to
commit insurance fraud yay yup this
their insurance fraud sir sometimes
gamers win boomers technology jamesy
dumb [ __ ] you need to switch over to
HDMI one grandpa
dumb [ __ ] Jack Nicholson Joaquin
Phoenix Mark Hamill dodge jared leto
cut at the Jared it's joke because he
jared leto is one hey another one
look beer boob epic
me taking the pizza rolls out of the
oven my dog Vicki he's gotta get what
that's a great room I like that one a
lot
some actors were bored to play certain
not you roles there it is is it true
that Jarrod later like complain about
his performance he was upset jack told
me that jared leto did like method
acting which is basically an excuse to
act like a dickwad on set
so basically jared leto let out rats and
[ __ ] it unsent ya hear male rats to his
team mailing rats mailing bullets you
were just like insane I don't really
embrace the joke I did embrace the Joker
and I had a lot of fun with it and you
know he's a fun guy
what the hell is wrong with you don't do
that eleven obnoxious things Jared Leto
has done as a joker used condoms and
anal but nailed used condoms delivered a
dead pig mailed Margot Robbie and live
riotous is true doesn't matter I don't
like him me resolving one problem there
is another there is always more problems
why they never end
why problem never ends explain explain
yourself problem I have a problem right
now I have no more Joker memes but I'm
gonna rape joke and memes 10 because I
love no I'm gonna rate the Joker memes
11 because it rises up and goes beyond I
also realized I never rated the 49 meme
zero cool next babe oh wait did I miss
something bye miss - Joker means let me
see
well I'm glad we got that out of the way
at least so what I'm funny now I'm a
funny guy just cuz I'm dressed like a
clown I suppose you think I shouldn't
have a gun either jontron predicted the
Joker film well done jontron well played
mission to the next meme the next meme
needs a little bit of context it's a
whole dispute with the Hong Kong and
China for those who don't know Hong Kong
is a semi-autonomous state from China it
has his own lost lost Testament or
jurisdiction I don't
English is hard already and I don't know
exactly how it works but it's sort of
like its own state and in China
obviously wants to change that and Hong
Kong is like nah we want to be free and
then I don't know where someone from NBA
tweets something saying I support Hong
Kong and then NBA is like oh god we need
Chinese money so they it just spirals
out of control and then the exact same
thing happens during a blizzard
livestream we're one of the contestants
who won the tournament calls out his
support for Hong Kong I think he said
like liberate Hong Kong ethnically or
something like that and these two people
the coasters gets fired and blisters
response to this because obviously China
is like that one person on Twitter that
can't take any criticism and just blocks
everyone so Blizzard to appease China
fires the hosts and vans the winner and
takes away all his prize money because
blizzard needs Chinese money obviously
the biggest amount of sales in mobile
games always comes from China
remember when Blizzard announced that
the habló mobile version and everyone's
like is this a April Fool's joke well
from a business standpoint no it isn't
it makes perfect sense to get that
Chinese mobile market and that's really
all they care about I think it's very
important to remember this because
companies they might put up a face they
might put up a rainbow flag and yes
that's good in a way but at the end of
the day their goal is to make money they
don't care about you they don't care
about freedom and unless people push
back at companies they're not gonna do
anything
South Park which also at this time made
fun of this whole concept god bless you
South Park how Disney and and many films
chain
they're Chinese version in cinema just
to please China it's all about pleasing
China and following Chinese rule pity
pipe cheap fuel flavor
lingonberry is out link in description
buy yours now it is a really good flavor
it tastes just like memes and dreams and
a little bit of meatballs so the thing
is like obviously I wanted to have
meatball flavor cheap yeah it wouldn't
taste epic but it is a tradition in
Sweden to have Ling on with meatballs a
lot of people don't eat them I don't
know why but it really makes the
meatballs so much better when the habit
Ling on so we made it out into a drink
gamers and it's really really good
honestly I'm so proud of this flavor it
is my favorite one and no bias intended
okay yeah just check it out if you buy
the collector's box you get one of the
shakers glows in the dark
along with gamer clout of course which
is the most important here's a picture
of me posing epically in front of it
here's me holding way too many of them
very epically Hong Kong meme gets and
that's it for me for now no bonus memes
sorry gamers not this time not this time
I had to sell my G fuel instead thanks
for watching thanks for subscribing and
oh one more important announcement is
something that's been on my mind for a
while and I think it's time to address
this seriously March by March buy it uh
you haven't tried to Bruce emulator
citizen E after 50 million outros fetch
down just down it's still relevant just
down a bit